[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler free review
of lock and key the new super hyped up
show on Netflix this story comes from
Joe Hill his graphic novels he is a son
of Stephen King and the creative team
behind it is the machete producers from
it Carlton Cuse from lost and Meredith
Averell from haunting of Hill House
you're actually an you get a drizzle of
all those things in the show if you're
into those shows and movies I'm already
gonna suggest you must watch this and
what this show basically is is if
stranger things and haunting a fill
house had a baby and he would think with
all the hype surrounding that and
comparisons it would clearly fail but it
does not I am shocked how good this show
is I really am it feels like Steven
Spielberg in his prime and if you're
turned off by supernatural things don't
be because this is one of those type of
supernatural stories it has enough heart
and mystery to it that you can get past
that it's worth it the acting here is
great it's a lot of fresh faces and the
writing here is super top-notch
I always value stories that put
characters first and this is one of
those but you get so much mystery to
keep you hooked and so many answers to
keep you satisfied it's just a great
balance I haven't seen that in a show in
a long time like that it's always too
much mystery and not enough answers or
no mystery you just get bored this never
feels boring if you're not totally sold
in the first three episodes give it time
because especially episode 5 the pace
really picks up and it does not let go
and with the show like this - it's not
overbearing in length it's ten episodes
but a lot of those episodes are about 45
minutes on the nose so I credit good
editing there - it doesn't have too much
meat on it every scene feels like it has
a purpose and I wouldn't say it's this
kiddie thing either remember it's based
off a graphic horror novel but they give
it a nice balance we're definitely more
for adults but you could definitely
watch it with teens for sure and it has
a lot of that vibe of stranger things
where it's appealing to most and it just
shocked me because
I just couldn't believe I was watching
this that Netflix is gonna get another
massive hit because this will be a
massive hit it has all the formula for
that it almost just feels unfair to
other streaming networks unfortunately I
really don't want to spoil anything
because it's so much mystery but I will
say there's not as much hard as you
might expect so if you're really going
for straight hard this isn't it it
really is more based in suspense and
mysteries and like I said Hart to the
story and characters being the main
focus
short and sweet I'm giving this one a
nine point two as a season after you
watch the whole season please make sure
to check out my spoiler review or I
really go in detail about every episode
and give my thoughts and why I'm giving
it such a high score but let me know
down below if you're gonna watch this
show if you're excited for it if you've
read the graphic novels I'd love to hear
all your thoughts on it and please make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss one
of my reviews I review a bunch of shows
movies and I do celebrity interviews as
well and please follow me at Steve are
the one on Twitter for more of me and
I'll see you next time